so I'm very excited to have bill schnoor
as moderator of this panel he is a
partner at goodwin procter his clients
include Zendesk hubspot athenahealth and
in privada i'm sure many of you are very
familiar with these clients he is very
much at the center of the Boston tech
scene and in fact just completed the
Boston Marathon and joining him as guess
our Jeff Epstein who is the operating
partner of Bessemer ventures he serves
on the board of boards of director of
Kaiser Permanente the priceline group
and shutterstock and he previously was
CFO of Oracle as well as double-click in
addition to him we have David Rosen
blonde who was also part of double-click
he was a former CEO and presently as a
CEO of first dibs which is the world's
leading online marketplace for the most
rare and most desirable objects David is
on the board of Twitter and I see so I'm
sure many of you are familiar with many
of these companies so please join me in
welcoming onto the stage
okay thanks Victor for that warm intro
this is always perilous duty being the
last panel before cocktail hour
especially with a group of yell ease but
we'll do our best to hold your interest
and attention so what we're going to
talk about we've got about it's about 40
minutes and we're going to have some Q&A
at the end we're going to be addressing
the issue of transformations you'd from
the boardroom so I think that you know
for particularly for younger
entrepreneurs it's really important to
recognize your all ultimately driving
your businesses probably in most cases
ultimately be taken out in an
acquisition by a bigger company you know
the IPO opportunities always there but
that's frankly a little bit of the rarer
way to get out and so ma becomes pivotal
and in that role understanding how
directors think and how they include
ultimately decisions for really big
deals and hopefully you are selling for
a really large amount is made in the
boardroom so we've got two speakers here
today with just phenomenal experience
both as directors and executives of
bigger companies the acquirers and also
the emerging companies the targets that
prey but since we are talking about
transformation what I want to do at the
outset Jeff and david has asked you each
just to reflect back on your career and
the changes you've seen and what's an
example of transformation that kind of
really sticks out your mind the business
model can be technology market you name
it okay terrific thank you very much
bill and thank you to the Yale community
for inviting us to be here it's great to
be here and before I answer that
question i'll just point out that Dave
and I have a lot in common we both went
to Yale undergrad we both went to
Stanford Business School work in the
technology business but you just have to
be prepared if you go to Yale and work
in technology to lose your hair that's
the part
so I'm go to law school I've been on a
board of priceline now for 12 years and
priceline has is just a remarkable story
it went public in 1998 and very quickly
grew to a 30 billion dollar market value
during the internet bubble and Priceline
score promised to consumers at the time
was name your own price and it was name
your own price for airlines and then it
was name your own price for mortgages
and groceries and gasoline and there was
a thesis in 1998 at a 30 billion dollar
market value that price line would
become the discount version of Walmart
and become a giant ecommerce company and
that turned out not to happen and so you
talk about transformation when the
internet bubble burst and all of these
other businesses other than travel
turned out to be enormous money losers
Priceline stock went down 99 percent so
went down from 30 billion dollars to
three hundred million dollars was losing
a lot of money people thought priceline
was going to go out of business and I
joined the board in 2003 when it had
recovered a little bit its market value
is about a billion dollars and we did
transform the company at the time it was
only named we had at that point they had
cut back everything other than name your
own price airline travel and what were
able to do is we were able to go from
just name your own price to regular
airline travel and then we added
neighbor on priced hotels and regular
hotels and then we grew internationally
and we made an acquisition in the UK and
Europe and Asia of hotel travel agents
and today we are the largest hotel
travel agent in the world and the market
value of the company is 60 billion
dollars so to go from 30 billion to 300
million to 60 billion over the course of
17 years there's been quite a
transformation so like my Boston Red Sox
going from World Series to last place to
rest thanks Jeff David how about you
yeah it's a difficult question because
almost by definition any successful
internet company ends up disrupting its
industry and therefore representing its
own
kind of example of transformational miss
you know I guess for my direct
experience the one that has been the
most spectacular was was the industry
that we created a double click and
actually I guess it's not just our hair
that we have in common that the double
click story minus a few zeros sort of
follows a similar path to that or
priceline the company was founded in
nineteen ninety six by mid-2015 billion
dollar market cap we were public about
18 months later we had a negative
enterprise value meaning our market
value was less than the amount of cash
that we had we ended up taking the
company private and really pivoting the
business around the double-click Ad
Exchange and essentially the story
behind that was you know we we developed
technology that basically acted as the
kind of platform for all display
advertising on the internet most of that
industry was run similar to the way it
was offline meaning advertising was
bought and sold kind of the
old-fashioned way over three-martini
lunches and the like and we supported
that process in mid 2005 we perceived
that Google was directly focused on
disrupting us and at this point the
details don't really matter but our a
competitive response was to try to shift
the way advertising was bought and sold
in the display category and basically
what we were trying to accomplish was
changing from a model where advertising
was bought and sold away in the way that
i described over lunch in a very sort of
structured way with long-term plans and
so on to one that looked much more like
the way financial securities are bought
and sold through a marketplace live real
time where there are no long-term
commitments most of it is done via
computer screen rather than face to face
that industry which is called
programmatic is now you know probably a
40 to 50 billion dollar industry and I
was really almost entirely driven by the
commercialization of the double-click Ad
Exchange which not only disrupted the
industry but also disrupted our own
historical business we ended up selling
the company to Google and in mid 2008
and you know the the business as it is
today is I think in gross media terms
and gross revenue terms is second only
at Google to search in in size great
thanks so so now let's shift our focus
into the boardroom now looking at it
from this point of view not of the
emerging company but the established the
bigger company a company that's got a
great market position profitable
business growing note a decent clip but
not robustly suddenly faced with the
risk of transformation its market so
let's say your Oracle and you've got
this great enterprise license model and
maintenance fees and all of a sudden the
cloud comes in SAS emerges or your IBM
and your dominant in mainframes and all
of a sudden everybody's running around
with with pcs as a board member as a
member senior management how do you know
when it's time to not just try to stop
hoping that the change won't happen and
recognize the change for what it is and
then adapt to it either by changing your
business or going out and buying
something how do you do that I'm gonna
give you two answers the first is how a
company like Oracle thinks about
acquisitions in general and then how it
reacts to something like a disruption
change like like cloud computing so
Oracle has a phenomenal acquisition
strategy and it starts with the product
so the engineers will look at a customer
a type of customer like well go to JP
Morgan and they'll say to JP Morgan tell
us about all the 10,000 different
enterprise software products you use you
have something to monitor mortgages
trading credit cards consumers you have
an HR system you've got all these
different internal systems to run your
bank and literally there could be 10,000
different applications and so we would
then create a map of all the different
applications and technology systems
security other things that a major money
center bank would be buying from
enterprise software provider and we
would Code Red products where oracle had
a competitive product in that category
and then we leave it white if Oracle
either didn't have a product or we had a
product that for whatever reason is old
or not
very good and then the product managers
would say over time we want the entire
chart to be red we want to be able to
sell every product to jpmorgan and so we
would have a build or buy approach so
there might be hundreds of boxes
initially that are white and the product
managers would work with the customers
with the salespeople and they would
decide to prioritize which of these
features and functionality and
categories within a money center banks
application profile would be the highest
priority we then say if we put 100
engineers on this project for two years
we could build a competitive product or
we could buy one of these six companies
that are independent that are out there
and would go through this build or buy
option and then simultaneously companies
are calling us all the time or
investment bankers are calling us saying
this company's for sale if one of these
companies happens to be a credit card
processing company that sells to
JPMorgan we'd fit it into the matrix and
we'd say where does that how does that
change our build a versus x and over the
last 12 years oracle has grown probably
about half and half half through
internally developed software and half
through acquisitions which they then put
through their machine now that's just in
general about all acquisitions and then
when you have something that's
completely transformative like cloud
computing there are there are a couple
of issues one is often it starts if
you've read innovators dilemma it starts
at the low end so it starts with smaller
companies Oracle just starts selling to
the fortune 500 so we didn't focus
initially on products that were sold to
companies with 100 or 500 employees but
the profit the suppliers that sell to
those small companies get better and
better over time and also they're
generally cheaper and so if we started
competing initially we would have to
have a lower functional product with a
much lower price and much less profit
and we'd be trading dollars of revenue
for dimes of revenue and that doesn't
make any sense so it's very natural that
in new markets the incumbent is slow to
innovate because innovation means
cannibalizing your own business and
Larry Ellison the founder and see and
now chairman of Oracle I think did a
pretty good job of seeing cloud
computing coming he personally was an
angel investor in sale
course he personally founded NetSuite no
one's half of netsuite but he was slow
in having oracle invest in cloud
computing because he wanted to keep
Oracle's profits up and then i would say
about four or five years ago he went
all-in we Oracle's been spending
billions of dollars now both internally
developing clouds product products and
acquiring cloud products at high prices
and the the story is not over so we'll
have to see Oracle's got about 35
billion dollars in revenue maybe ten
percent or less as cloud and you've got
to manage that transition so that as
cloud becomes bigger and bigger you're
you've got a big enough part of your
business that's that's in this
fast-growing business and we'll have to
see whether they can do that great
thanks Jeff David yeah so you know it's
interesting the Oracle listening to Jeff
Oracle's point of view obviously
originates from a company that's
fundamentally b2b business meaning
they're selling the businesses as
opposed to consumers you know I think
the I think the approach among consumer
companies is probably slightly different
which is in almost any case I think you
have to assume that the disruptive
thread puts your entire business at
stake and you know it's funny the kind
of expression that always comes to mind
when I have these conversations is I
remember early in the advertised digital
advertising industry having a
conversation with some people about sort
of the relationship future relationship
between television or offline
advertising and digital advertising and
the question of the time is you know do
they converge and if so at what point
and so on and finally someone said you
know I think the two are probably going
to converge in the same way that the car
and the horse and buggy did so you want
you want to be in a car so I in consumer
businesses you know that very often
tends to be the case companies really
can go to zero and the disruptor can
fully displace the incumbent and so
therefore i think is the the larger
company the one that's at risk of being
disrupted in all cases you got to take
it really seriously and make sure that
you know i would say you both have an
organic effort pointed at that thread
and also an acquisition effort
did you know there are legion examples
you know probably the simplest one that
I was involved with was Google and
YouTube so when YouTube originated and
gain scale very quickly google launched
something called google video which none
of you have ever used and probably don't
remember and that didn't really work and
at the same time they had enough her to
buy youtube and obviously that did work
and hit up YouTube no probably a you
know seven or eight billion dollar
revenue company now and continuing to
grow quickly you know you can look back
on roads not taken you know in the in
the in the kind of social industry for
example you know should a Twitter have
bought on Instagram sat at Facebook you
know one could argue both sides of that
equation but I'm clearly Instagram ended
up being a regal company and important
in that category and so I think again
the short answers you gotta do both you
have to build organically and you have
to look at M&A and I think in the case
where you look at M&A i think it's it's
you look at valuations like whatsapp and
so on that seemed very big people
thought that youtube price is enormous
at the time i think if you're right that
the company that you're looking at
really is going to be the disruptor
almost no price can be too high they all
look smart in retrospect and you know
the last point on this is when you look
at the really successful large-cap
consumer tech companies like a google
like a facebook almost all of their new
products were formed via kind of small
tuck-in acquisitions that they then sort
of plugged into the Machine and made
much bigger and more successful you know
Google in particular you look at
something like Android you know that was
acquired Maps was acquired to be a
company called keyhole you know and on
and on in fact they're very few of the
of the products that really matter at
google today search in chrome are
probably the two that come to mind were
philly fully built organically facebook
is doing the same thing the Instagram
and whatsapp and others potentially
oculus falls into that category so you
really have to be good at
that both as a short answer okay so Dave
let me come back to you with a follow-up
and Jeff could have a shot at this to
you mentioned valuation and you
mentioned some really high profile high
value deals when you're sitting as a
director on the buying company side how
do you get comfortable evaluation how do
you think about valuation how do you you
know know that the management just
hasn't fallen in love with the target
because presumably no matter how great
the acid is is a price which it just
doesn't make sense and you know how does
that dialogue take place behind closed
doors but a cinema switch you trade
secrets here yeah well honey Jeff is the
former CFO I'm the former operator so
I'm the guy falls in love with companies
and he's the one who says you know old
your horses look I you know there's no
simple answer to that because again as I
was saying earlier when a company that
when you end up buying a leader in a big
market again in retrospect almost any
price is justifiable I mean if you know
again people thought the Google spending
a billion five for YouTube seem crazy
you know if they'd spend three times
that in retrospect it would have paid
out Facebook my Instagram for a billion
dollars again seemed like a gigantic
number at the time the company was 18
months old that had something like you
know 30 million users again you know
many people believe Instagram is a
substantial percentage of Facebook's
market cap today so again I you know I
think that it really boils down less
from my point of view and in the kinds
of companies that I've been involved
with less to a financial basis and more
to a strategic basis and that's the role
that boards play is really kind of
drilling in on the on the kind of
strategic rationale and logic and and
and and sort of getting comfortable with
that because if you get comfortable
there again you should be relatively
price and sensitive if you can't get
uncomfortable you know almost any price
is too much and so it's somewhat of a
binary result I agree with David that
you have to be you have to catch these
companies at the right time that are
extraordinary companies but you also
have to be right and there are famous
examples of people who have been wrong
so News Corp famously bought myspace
when it was growing 100
percent a year thinking it was going to
be Facebook and they were wrong I think
perhaps they didn't manage it correctly
but it could also be that myspace was
just a much weaker company than Facebook
and no one could have managed it well
and myspace would have declined anyway
so paying a high price for a
fast-growing company is very risky and
there I think there are two ways to look
at it one is the sooner from a portfolio
approach if you were going to buy this
company as a standalone company will
this be a good investment on its own
it's sort of a Berkshire Hathaway
approach or private equity approach or
venture capital approach and then but as
a company you have an additional
advantage which is there may very well
be things you can do with that company
that other people can't and so it's
worth more to you than someone else and
then what you want to think through is
how will how will your revenue be higher
your cost be lower on a combined basis
than otherwise and so I think a great
example of that is when ebay bought
paypal initially ebay paypal was a
start-up which was a payment service
which turned out to largely be used by
ebay sellers and ebay had its own
payment system which wasn't as good they
didn't do a very good job of executing
and so ebay bought paypal rolled it out
to all their cellars and it was
phenomenal synergy initially and then
paypal grew to be so successful that
today PayPal's business is largely non
ebay sellers and now you have these two
companies paypal which is a payments
company in ebay which is the ecommerce
company which have some overlap but
don't really have that much in common
and if you say where should pay pal
really exists it probably should exist
inside a larger financial institution so
ebay and paypal now are in the process
of splitting up and it would not at all
surprised me if two years from now some
big bank or Visa or MasterCard buys
paypal and the paypal asset which made a
lot of sense to be part of ebay for
several years now makes a lot of sense
to be part of some giant multinational
financial institution and that's why
these mergers and acquisitions happen
because assets at one point in time have
create value by being higher revenue
lower costs as part of one other group
of companies and then over time the
world changes and it's more valuable as
part of another group of companies
great so so now it's just our focus not
from the boardroom of the buyers but the
boardrooms of the targets the emerging
companies you know there's been a lot of
high-value acquisitions of relatively
early stage companies i mean i think it
deep mines which was acquired by google
i think the company had six employees it
was a several hundred million dollar
deal we're seeing more of those so when
you're sitting on the target side how do
you weigh the benefits in the trade-offs
of an early sale where you know there's
there's not been from the founders point
of view not that much dilution still
meaningful ownership but presumably
early enough in the process of you're
leaving a lot of potential money on the
table in terms of aggregate enterprise
value okay but with the right all the
risks that continued success entails and
the dilution from your financing sadia
how do you weigh and wrestle those the
current pay day versus the future payday
not so you're saying that if someone in
this room for instance has a company and
they get an offer for 500 million
dollars good they take know since
companies leery hat we don't have a
single customer we've got a professor
into grad students and there's an offer
on the table to buy it for 50 million
dollars well I'll take it ok so I'll
give you my personal view which is third
company there's a certain amount of
money which will change your life you
know a million dollars may not change
your life but 10 or 20 or 50 million
dollars will completely change your life
and if you have a company that where you
can make change your life kind of money
and you don't take it and then the
market crashes or the Russian ruble
collapses whatever and then it you get
wiped out you sort of will probably feel
pretty bad about it but there there are
way your spouse punch it was over so my
guess my personal advice for most people
would be either to take the sale or to
figure it's just try to get a secondary
so you could sell some of your stock at
that very high evaluation because you've
seen these just incredible changes in
the capital markets that come and go and
and that could be sort of a one-time
type of thing so I think it makes it
it's very rational for people to do that
and in one way to think about it is take
some money probably the rational thing
to do is to take some money off and keep
some money on it because you can do that
right yeah that's what I was going to
say I mean to me the biggest change in
the market in that respect is the
development of these markets
that permit for founders to sell some
portion of their stock I mean you know
until very recently that wasn't the case
and so you always have this binary
decision of you know do I sell the dream
or do I own the dream and owning the
dream carried a lot of risk now you
don't have to make that decision
actually so the right answer I think it
is that take some money off the table
and and hold on to the company and you
know see if you can make a go of it i
will say from the entrepreneurs point of
view the opposite of the phenomenon that
i described for big companies is is true
for them in other words for big
companies my point is at least in the
consumer market you know no price is too
high for a company that's going to be
successful but that's also true from the
point of view of the entrepreneur a
price that can seem extraordinarily high
at an early stage in the company's
development actually can look quite
small with the benefit of hindsight five
years later if the company is successful
and that's happened you know time and
time again and people have left you know
tremendous sort of intergenerational
amounts of wealth on the table by by
taking that you know that that check and
again I think if you can sort of
accomplish away it's not that easy to do
to get the best of both worlds by
getting some liquidity but retaining
exposure to the ultimate opportunity
that's where you want to that's where
you want to be if i can just described
by some Priceline's done extremely well
they are expert at acquiring companies
founded by entrepreneurs and structuring
the deal in a way that continues having
the entrepreneur stay at the company and
become have a big stake in the game so
several times now we've bought seventy
or eighty percent of a company leaving
twenty or thirty percent in the hands of
the founders and then having buy-sell
agreements over the next three years
where in every case that we've done this
the company has done so much has grown
so quickly that the twenty or thirty
percent that they kept was worth more
than the seventy or eighty percent they
sold initially because the valuation per
share was so high and so that was just
price line has been extraordinary in
finding these great companies run by
brilliant entrepreneurs keeping them
motivated keeping them
excited to stay within the priceline
world making sure they get rich but also
having that entrepreneurial energy
within a big company and that's pretty
rare most most of the time big companies
acquire entrepreneurs the entrepreneurs
want to leave as quickly as they can to
get app from the bureaucracy so that's
pretty rare ability for a large company
that has great yeah that also applies in
some cases to startups with in big
companies in the probably the best known
example and a public one with a company
I'm involved with is a product many of
you hopefully have used tinder you know
which which was started under the
auspices of IAC and it's been again
pretty well publicized the founders
retained a chunk of that and you know
it's done it's done extremely well so
tender have any revenue yeah it does
okay so here's the one of the internal
questions on that we should kick around
have some photo hf you wouldn't know
these are not a user or but there are
there hey p i know they had a lot of
users but my impression when i was i was
wondering whether it's a hobby or a
business that was my shell busy vote so
our companies bought or they sold
targets lee boyd of a soul so I mean
what you you've run corporate
development departments right well
there's a famous saying in technology in
particular and software that companies
are bought not sold and I think the
point is when I was describing this the
JP morgan's sheet that Oracle had if you
come to Oracle and you say I've got this
great product and we sell software for
dentists and it's phenomenal opportunity
oreck would say well we don't sell
separate identities we don't care so
it's not of interest to us but if if we
have software selling to banks to help
manage credit cards that we're very
interested so I think the point is large
companies have their own strategic plan
about where they want their products and
customers to be from product point of
view customer second point of view jerk
geographical point of view a business
model point of view whether it's
on-premise or SAS and they're going to
go through that they're going to do that
strategy and then build or buy as a
technique and so if you happen to be a
company and you fit into that strategy
if they're doing their jobs they should
be they should
know who you are already they should be
talking to you and trying to wine and
dine use that when you're ready to sell
now it could be that may be your best
fit is with a smaller company they don't
have too many corporate development
people so as a entrepreneur it's a very
good idea for you to build relationships
with the five or ten companies that
might eventually acquire you so they
know who you are they see how that you
could fit in their their their plan
again on a b2b basis if you just call up
a company if you're the seller and you
call up a company so you've never heard
of me but we have a great business
you're I think you are not likely to get
a good response yeah it's what I would
say most companies for that reason or
bought every company should be sold and
you know my advice to people who run
companies I'm involved with is you
should always they be thinking about the
cell option and the sort of analogy that
I always use and you know what I haven't
do you use is the the kind of you know
stolen from the intelligence business
where you know there's a sort of concept
of sleeper cells meaning you sort of
have people in different countries and
ninety-nine percent of the time you
don't use them but if you need to use it
you have people that you can sort of
activate and you know can go into action
very quickly and the way this sort of
the way that works with M&A is I think
any small company should should always
be thinking about sort of what is the
possible exit path and building
relationships with logical acquirers and
again I don't think it takes a lot of
time it could just be as simple as
having a relationship with the relevant
biz dev or Corp deaf person so at least
they kind of understand what you're
doing you can have that meeting in the
context of you know business development
opportunities but the value of that is
so when the big company like an Oracle
shows up and says we want to buy you
because you fit into this white space an
hour you know two by two matrix for a
given market you know what they're going
to try to do is they're going to try to
make it non competitive because that
results in a lower price what your goal
should be as an entrepreneurs to make it
as competitive possible if you have zero
relationships outside of that one
acquirer you don't have the time to do
it it's too hard and also you know you
risk alienating the buyer on the other
hand or the original buyer on the other
hand if you have
see sleeper cell you can very easily
kind of in the background you know call
them up and say look you know we're not
necessarily selling the company but you
know we do have this option and you know
to the extent that you're interested in
exploring that as well you know we need
to know in the next two days and it
doesn't it doesn't you don't have to
sort of cycle through all sorts of all
sorts of meetings and you can create an
auction very quickly and at that point
the risk of the original bitter walking
away is a lot lower because you know
that bitter then puts themselves at risk
of their competitor owning the company
and my understanding is that you know
Oracle's sort of participated in a bunch
of those things and ended up you know
Oracle and Salesforce and ended up
spending a lot more money than they had
originally planned simply in order to
not lose the the asset that they decided
was very important strategically well I
think David you lived through two of
these auctions at double-click which had
very different outcomes so I think
people would be interested in the first
sale of the company when it was a public
company sold to private equity and then
the second sale when you had this kind
of competition maybe tell us yeah well
the first sale I mean the other rule of
thumb which again creates a real
difficult judgment call is the best time
to sell a company is when you don't have
to and the worst type is when you don't
really have a choice so you know I did
this sort of summary of what job is
talking about is you know to sort of cut
back to 2000 if you recall you know we
had this 15 billion dollar murky cab
part of the reason the market cap shrank
so much as we got caught up in the
dot-com meltdown but the other part is
we made some really bad strategic
decisions we basically responded to the
dot-com meltdown and the opposite way
that we should have what we should have
done is double down on our core business
and emerged from the you know down cycle
in a much stronger competitive and
market share position instead what we
did is we diversified away from that
core business to the extent that when
the market turned in 2004 in a positive
direction we were no longer the proxy on
the on the online advertising market
that that we should have been and we had
been going into the cycle as a result
the company significantly underperformed
and the board decided to
all the business it was a controlled
sale all the buyers knew that we had to
sell the company we weren't performing
particularly well and so we had no
leverage and as a result helmet and
Friedman which is the private equity
company that ended up owning us by the
company at a very low price conversely
in you know fast forward four years
later to 2008 the way we sold the
company at that time was company was
doing great we were growing revenues at
you know 60 ish percent a year on a
roughly at four or five hundred million
dollar revenue base strategically we
were in a great position we had just
launched this ad exchange which you know
even at the moment felt like it was
going very well and so basically the way
my sort of approach to it was and you
know so my approach to it was I kind of
had two choices sell the company try to
sell the company or you know do the
default thing of working through an IPO
and so on you know to tie back to some
earlier points that Jeff made I ended up
deciding to sell the company and the
reason to be totally honest was the
alternative of going public was just not
very appealing you know as a manager
once your public you can't just sell all
your stock in one day you have to sort
of dribble it out over five years it
looks bad you have to explain everybody
why you keep on selling stock meanwhile
your investors you know can sell like
that once their lock up comes up so you
know to them an IPO equals liquidity
right but to the management team it
doesn't which means you're subject to
the market whims and there were no
mechanisms at that time to be able to
take some money off the table so it was
an all-or-nothing thing so on that basis
I tried to explore the the option of
selling the company and basically the
way I did it was I went out to one
bitter again I had this sort of sleeper
cell of relationships at some of the
large gap internet tech companies I went
to one of them and I kind of induced
them over three or four months and help
them sort of build a strategy to to make
a bid for us and then really I turn
around and in kind of two or three days
was able to do what I suggested everyone
else do which is you know I was in a
position to call these other companies
and say look you know this company will
get sold you
have to take a look at it but if you
want to you need to do it very quickly
and you need to make a decision very
quickly and so that led to an auction
among three companies Google Yahoo and
Microsoft and that resulted in you know
in a successful sale of the business at
a good price but what really drove that
we entered up probably doubling the
ultimate price over the initial bid and
that was a hundred percent a result of
competition vs the first instance where
there was no competition and everybody
knew that if nobody bid you know we
would be you know we would not be in a
good situation and in fact we in that
case we got a very low price which is
again why I would strongly urge you as
entrepreneurs to always think about sort
of building this competitive set because
whether you're raising money privately
from venture investors or growth
investors or you know selling a hundred
percent of your equity to an acquirer
sort of doesn't matter in all cases
you're selling something you're selling
equity and the more people who want it
the better price you're going to get so
David you're being very modest about the
value that you added during that three
or four year period just give people a
sense of what was the opening bid and
what was the bid the closing bid yeah so
the opening bid was arranged actually a
little bit less than fifty percent or
less than double but the original range
was 1.6 to 1.8 billion dollars for the
company and to cut a long story short we
ended up selling it for 3.1 billion
dollars but the interesting coda to that
story is at the end of it after resolved
so one of the bidders it's Microsoft to
CEO is Steve Ballmer who as though he
probably knows real low-key good yeah
exactly probably the single most
aggressive kind of testosterone driven
guy in the world he's he's he's in the
right exactly the right job for him
right now owning an NBA team and and and
so after the whole thing was announced
you know he called me like within about
five minutes actually the announcement
and he said you know gratulations on the
sale you should just know you know you
left at least a billion dollars on the
table by not giving me the last look and
you know for various reasons the terms
of
the negotiations when with Google we
weren't able to and then in fact he went
out four months later paid twice as much
six billion for another company
aquantive that he thought did a similar
thing to us but which didn't and whoops
a year later Microsoft wrote down you
know six billion of the 6.1 billion
dollars worth that they paid for it you
know there by validating the point that
we had made to him which is there was in
fact no company like us except the time
so I there's a question I've always
wanted to ask you so now i can ask you
because you're on a public forum is when
you go to yahoo and you work for them
with them for two or three months and
say look you should bid to buy our
company and then the next day you call
Google and Microsoft and say Yahoo's bid
do you want to top it we ought who knew
you were going to do that how do you get
yahoo to bid knowing they're just
setting up to be topped by somebody else
isn't that isn't that very delicate
conversation they they told us at the
time five different ways you know if you
shop this you know we're out of here and
so yeah I mean the sort of there's a
heart in mouth moment I think to every
significant transaction and mine in that
case was when I picked up the phone to
call the other guys but but you know it
was sort of a calculated vet and you
have to take risks and life and you know
part of the advantage though what what
gives you more courage in that is if the
core business is performing well you
know it makes you a lot braver because
it means that you're you know as they as
they sort of say in business cold your
Batna your best alternative to a
negotiated agreement you know your Batna
is not bad it's not as good as selling
the company at a at a premium but it's
it's not bad that plus the fact that I
had again built this sort of sleeper
cell and you know I knew that there were
individuals in each of the other bidders
who very quickly could articulate the
argument for why they needed to own it
and why be really bad for for them if
somebody else sounded so when you made
that call you took a risk maybe a
calculated risk but you took a risk that
Google and Microsoft wouldn't be
but yahoo would find out get upset and
withdraw their bid so there was yeah or
somewhere in the middle that you know
Google Microsoft would take a long time
in the meat you know yahoo would find
out they would pull out and then
everyone would seem to make us less
attractive yeah and it sort of has this
self-reinforcing effect I'll tell you
one other funny story is I mean for some
reason in the first in that in the doors
that one week where we were sort of
flying around the country and in kind of
giving the the company presentation to a
much larger acquisition team and each of
the acquirers and so we had this meeting
at Yahoo we had the meeting at Microsoft
for some reason the meeting with Google
to do this was in New York and so my
partner and I who who ran product at the
time took the red-eye back from Seattle
back to New York to present to google
and in the in the microsoft meeting and
at the time microsoft regarded google as
its biggest competitor and vice versa
and for some reason so as part of the
presentation we had a model that said
you know this is the value to Microsoft
of owning double click and then same
thing to google and so you know here in
this hotel room is like packed yeah and
well we'd sort of gone through the deck
on the red-eye meaning neither of us
slept a minute on the way there and we
basically did a kind of find and replace
Microsoft or Google on the deck and when
we got to the presentation we went
through eighty percent of it it was
totally fine and then we got to the kind
of Excel spreadsheet which we had pasted
it into a PowerPoint slide and at the
bottom it said value to Microsoft owning
google and I remember there was this
Susan Wojcicki whose fantastic who was
the sort of executive sponsor of this
deal and now runs youtube said you know
excuse me you know why does that say
Microsoft and honestly my partner and i
were so tired and we weren't thinking
well on our feet and so I didn't say
anything he said it's a typo
but we we accomplished our mission and
then you know we had bankers and it was
interesting you know we had bangers in
the room from Morgan Stanley and you
know I guess they seized the opportunity
without talking to us you know the next
day in the Wall Street Journal there was
an article that said you know Microsoft
evaluating enough of a purchase of
double click which I think further
incited both yahoo and google it's now
in the morgan stanley playbook yeah 17
not so simple right so we only have a
few more minutes and i just want to get
it any questions for this group yes sir
what you mean taking money from a
corporate change event reserve as
opposed to a yeah okay i'll give you my
point of view which is i think your
first responsibility as an entrepreneur
is to have your company be well enough
funded and so you know if you get if the
best offers from a corporate and you
don't have compelling offers from
alternatives then you got to take it i
will say that in almost all cases the
court but not all the corporate
investment comes with both a board seat
from that company and a promise of some
sort of strategic help and i would say
just for my experience in almost every
single case and they're obviously
exceptions the the corporate guy who
who's on your board you know within a
year is a sign to something else as a
different job leaves he's either not
replace Tory's replaced by someone else
it doesn't really understand the
business or why the investment was made
originally and you know add bastid
becomes neutral at worse it becomes this
person you have to deal with it doesn't
really understand what you do or why you
know he or she is there and then
similarly from the the sort of synergy
we're kind of operation with synergy
side you know usually it doesn't really
pan out because it's incredibly
important to the to the target company
it's not particularly important to the
to the investor again team switch
strategy shift priorities shift even
within companies and so to the extent
assuming you do have a choice between a
corporate or strategic and a financial
investor and terms and all that kind of
stuff or roughly comparable and
valuation is roughly comparable and you
have this choice I would just say you
know be careful of being seduced by the
promises that of what the big company
can deliver and just make sure that you
know yes you trust on one hand but on
the other you verify and you make sure
that whatever value you expect to get is
is you know is to the extent you can is
you know both contractually and also
support it and also supported by the CEO
and that you get some kind of you know
as much of a commitment as you can
that it'll actually happen because
chances are even if you get that it's
probably not going to materialize I just
said that you know and having that's all
I think right on the mark there is
always a risk with one strategic
investor that the world sees you is just
not no longer truly independent actor
that you're somehow in their sphere of
influence the best way to inoculate
yourself against that is to try to find
to strategics at once and I kind of
learned this lesson only from clients I
learned a lot of things when I represent
a company called Red Hat was doing its
initial series a financing with
benchmark and Greylock they were an open
source operating system linux was their
product this was at a time when the idea
of open source code the enterprise was
novel and somewhat exotic and so the
management team wanted the validation of
having some strategic it an IBM was very
interested in putting money in we
concluded that the best way to avoid
being seen as IBM vassal state was to
find another strategic it so novell came
in alongside them so well it was time
for one more yes sir
did you hear could you repeat the
question I'm not sure Oh to a corporate
VC well they're there a couple of
answers to that one is there are
different kinds of corporate VCS so for
instance comcast ventures and essay p
ventures are organized like regular
venture capital firms they have an
independent fund the partners get a fee
and carry in the fund they are paid only
on the financial return on the
investments whereas other corporate
venture funds like Intel they are paid
their executives of Intel they might
come into the venture group and then
leave the venture group and their
incentive is to improve Intel's business
not make a financial return so if you
are a financial fun like set up like a
venture capital fund but where you're
only limited partners or corporation I
think you can make a very strong
argument that you're very similar to a
venture capital fund and then the second
thing you could do is if you're good and
in fact you add a lot of value for
instance if your comcast and you can say
look we can distribute your product in
50 million homes the United States
that's enormously valuable to you and
here are the five CEOs of portfolio
companies that we've vested in the last
five years call them up and ask them
what their life was like before we
invested and tell ask how many homes
they're distributed to now and Comcast
added enormous value then that's just a
tremendous thing to do so i think the
reference call if you are an
entrepreneur and you're getting
investment from anyone whether it's a
corporate venture capital firm or anyone
else the single most important thing for
you to do is to find CEOs that that
venture capital firm and that partner
have invested in before if you can find
a company that failed that that venture
capital firm and that partner arrested
before because the companies that are
good are going to be good references you
want to find the companies that struggle
the ones who are the ones that aren't on
the website anything right and and how
how did the venture capital investor how
good a partner were they when times were
tough and that's the
that's where it separates that the best
bc partners from whether that corporate
or not yes sorry i should read him I
can't reinforce that strongly enough and
it seems like no one ever really does it
but that is the only thing that matters
everyone is your friend when things go
well and you know what really separates
good firms from from not as good firms
is how they treat partners who do not do
well because the reality is the
likelihood is it you're not going to do
as well as you thought you were going to
and having supportive partners really
really is important you also on vest
errs with intellectual integrity
character and bessemer which is just
firm do you still have this for years
had their anti portfolio building up in
their website which would an
acknowledgement of deals they did not
invest in and turn down that went on to
great success okay that that that's a
think reflects very well invest more and
with that note I just want to thank our
speakers we're done thank you very much
terrific all right so we just want to
say a few closing remarks as we wrap up
today's first Yale tech conference in
New York City one of our hopes with
starting this alumni shared interest
group is to build a stronger community
of Y alias who are involved in
entrepreneurship and technology and I
think this is a fantastic start an event
like this really couldn't happen without
the support of many of our partners
we've had fantastic support from the
yellow entrepreneurial Institute the
Yale Club of New York City especially
sandy lee and andrew bezek the aya and
Mickey Dobbs General Assembly paper g
and goodwin procter & bill schnorr so
let's give a round of applause to all
the sponsors you all make this possible
we also had a fantastic volunteer team
today who helped to make everything run
smoothly so I just want to say thank you
to April Co Greg house sheer CC knee
Redeemer Steve Bogdan and Yong Zhao who
all helped us make this event run and
then of course to victor wong who is the
one of the organizers along with rich
and I so thank you to all our volunteers
for making this a great event
I just saw I just want to echo those
comments and one quick follow-up is just
a suggestion from personal experience
when the reason we get everybody
together is also to have people meet
each other yay Lee's are very friendly
there have been so many times that I've
reached out for help whether it's for
investment whether it's for advice and I
just would encourage everyone to both
seek help and offer help because that's
a something that's going to make our
community stronger and better and really
people in this community are incredible
with it so I'd encourage you to do that
and on that note Greg and CC have been
doing an incredible job organizing
events in New York City where their
regular meetups dinners events and so
would encourage you on the way out to
find them meet them sign up for the
email list some of the events have been
great and on I guess to end we have an
open bar upstairs in the 22nd floor with
a great view of New York and would love
to see you there too thanks everyone for
coming